hello everybody and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and today we're thinking about
the future implicitly of course we think
about the future a lot on this podcast
and elsewhere but today we're being a
bit more upfront about it
there are people who describe themselves
and are described by the outside world
as professional futurists whose job it
is to predict what will happen down the
road but there's this other genre which
is also very successful called science
fiction writing fictional narratives
that are often set in the future not
necessarily trying to predict exactly
what will happen but at least to imagine
different possible futures this helps us
think about how we should approach the
future as well as how we should approach
the present when I was a kid I was a big
science-fiction fan mostly reading
novels but also watching TV and movies
but I can tell you from reading more
recent science fiction that the level of
sophistication has gone way up both a
literary quality and also the scientific
quality of modern science fiction is as
high as it's ever been
in fact on today's podcast I put forward
the hypothesis that modern science
fiction writers are in some sense the
last great generalists because not only
do you have to understand a lot about
science you also have to understand a
lot about humanity so you need to
understand sociology and psychology and
you need to be able to write you need to
be able to tell a good story to invoke a
vivid world to invent interesting and
colorful characters so our guest today
Anna Lee Nuits is absolutely one of
those generalists someone who can think
in interesting ways about a wide variety
of things Anna Lee got her PhD in
English and American Studies from
Berkeley but then she became a writer
specializing in science and technology
she was the founder of the famous blog
io9 she was then the editor-in-chief of
Gizmodo and she's right now the editor
at large at ARS technica where she has a
very wide variety of experience writing
about both individual technological
breakthroughs and also the background
science behind these breakthroughs
recently Anna Lee has decided to turn
that experience to writing science
fiction she and science fiction writer
Charlie Jane Anders actually co-hosts
their own pod
which recently started it's called our
opinions are correct on which Charlie
Jane Annalee discussed the meaning of
science fiction I encourage you to check
that out and in her recent novel called
autonomous Annalee deals with the
biochemistry of pharmaceuticals the
ethics of robotics and artificial
intelligence and my favorite the
economics of what it means to have a
right to work she talks about slavery
and indenture and people trying to work
in different parts of the world we take
for granted the idea that we're allowed
to work but maybe in the future that
won't be the case this is the kind of
speculative scenario that science
fiction is perfectly made for so on the
podcast we'll talk about science
technology science fiction the
difference between writing the fiction
and nonfiction and how we should think
about what the future has in store so
let's go
[Music]
Annalee Nuits welcome to the mindscape
podcast yeah thanks for having me so I
was reading an article in Slate from a
few months ago by you and if I could
paraphrase the lesson it would be that
science fiction needs more economics in
it
is that accurate do you actually believe
that I actually do believe that I
thought it was very clever for coining
the phrase dismal science fiction it
really didn't really coin but it felt
like I did at the time and to sort of
describe this cluster of issues that
shows up in some science fiction novels
where and also some fantasy as well
where we kind of see characters
grappling with the economic dimensions
of what's going on whether that's space
travel and colonizing other worlds or
whether that's getting a grant to study
something which we didn't almost never
see in science fiction and it's like it
consumes the lives of scientists you
know it's actually like a big part of
how you define ants
it certainly is I just I just for the
audience out there read Anneliese
wonderful debut novel autonomous and
yeah there's a lot more about being the
principal investigator in that novel and
applying for grants than I read in
almost any other novel that I can
remember I've gotten a lot of
appreciative tweets from graduate
students saying last our labor has been
acknowledged and yeah I mean I think
that you know one of the things we talk
about a lot as science fiction writers
is world building and how do you make an
imaginary world feel lived in and feel
real so that your reader you know partly
so your reader has a fun experience but
also so that it actually inspires people
to really rethink reality which is you
know ultimately what we're writing about
since we don't actually travel into the
future and and report on it so and I and
I think that especially right now
you know economics are becoming
a really important part of how we think
about science how we deal with each
other what's shaping the future and so
you know some writers are dealing with
this more and more and and also
economists are you know really
interested in building scenarios about
the future too so I feel like there's a
lot of good opportunities there for us
to be thinking about basically thinking
about science in context if that makes
sense like sort of thinking about not
just like hey we discovered a new
particle but how did that happen like
how did this dude get to be the one who
discovered this particle out of all the
people who were working on the project
or like how did this project get the
funding that allowed them to discover
the particle like why did this particle
accelerator lose its funding you know
why did this one even though it has lots
of problems get to keep its funding you
know there's all these weird questions
that that sound really wonky but they're
actually part of making a really
exciting story because part of what's
fun is seeing people struggle to to get
what they want and that struggle isn't
just shooting particles down and
accelerator although that would be cool
if it were that would be cool but you're
right it's not exactly what it is I have
to ask before I forget have you read the
famous Paul Krugman article about the
economics of faster than light travel I
have yeah and that that's sparked a huge
debate I mean that was part of a huge
debate within the science fiction
community and people like Charles Stross
we're proposing for a while that we have
this kind of ultra realistic science
fiction mundane science fiction
basically where we were just like not
gonna have faster than light travel
because it was just absurd and so a few
people signed on for that and like
Charlie Straus wound up getting around
it by having
teleportation gates in his work and like
oh okay cuz that's just silly but
teleportation gates no prob
well you know we have standards for
ourselves and sayings for other people
that's okay but yeah I love this idea
about making it realistic and it it
making the world that you're creating
real
stick both in an economic sense as well
as a technological sense because after
all economics is a enormous influence on
how we live our lives at a very basic
level so it led me to the following
conjecture our science fiction writers
the last great generalists because of
all the stuff you have to know wow
that's a really interesting question I
mean I think it's really gonna depend on
the science fiction writer and also how
they view their relationship to science
because I think there's definitely
science fiction writers out there maybe
people like David Brin for example who
and and and I think a lot of kind of
writers who've now passed on who were
really popular in the 50s and 60s I
think they really thought of themselves
as like what we would probably today
call like a foresight analyst or a
futurist like they were I think they
really did not feel like they were
generalists who were commenting on the
world today but that they were actually
predicting things that would happen
based on you know what they knew of the
world a kind of well-informed prediction
and I think now yeah I mean some science
fiction writers for sure are generalists
one of the kind of big breakout new
voices in science fiction is Ann Leckie
who won like every award in the universe
for her ancillary justice series yeah
they're fantastic and I mean she deals
with everything like she deals with
economics she deals with space travel
she deals with AI she deals with
archaeology and so and I know from
talking to her that she is a voracious
reader and like she'll read everything
from you know medieval Chinese novels to
you know the latest you know articles
about discoveries in science so I think
you know she may be an outlier there
will be a spectrum right I mean it's not
every science fiction writer cares that
much to do the research and think about
these things at an academic level but
not only it seems like if you want
certain kind of writing not only do you
have to catch up on humanity and
economics and sociology and political
science and technology and physics and
biology but yet to be able to tell a
story so there's the humanities are in
there too
so it does strike me that the
best-equipped science fiction writers
are true generalists in the old-school
sense of the word yeah I think that's
right and it's funny because the the
novel that I'm writing right now which
won't be out for like a year so sorry
that I'm kind of teasing it a tiny bit
but it's like autonomous it has a lot of
academics in it scientists but also
social scientists and it's a it's set in
an alternate timeline where there is a
need for science and social science to
work hand in hand and basically be in
the same academic department so this is
a very kind of narrow is have some
teleportation machines in there it's
much I know there there is others Time
Machine so that's that's sort of what
has to happen right there hit you have
to have time machines in order to have
like an academic department which is
completely integrated social science and
science like physical sciences geology
and and so part of what I've been
thinking about a lot in this book is
where does social science fit into the
scientific project and I promise that
the book is actually just mostly people
running around in time machines and like
fighting and stuff but it's just like
one of these Law Review articles those
three lines of titles at the top and
then 100 lines footnotes small thing
yeah there are there there will actually
there will be an afterword with some
with some endnotes but it is but there
is this kind of like for people like I
said I mean you don't you won't need to
go into the novel being like I have some
thoughts about humanities and the
sciences but but that have been such
some of the characters are social
scientists and they're integral to this
scientific project and I was thinking
about exactly what you're saying with
storytelling and how what what
humanities and social sciences bring to
science are a sense of history and also
an ability to analyze social data which
is increasing
for especially in in the realm of
technology but in but also in a lot of
areas of things like you know
infrastructure design and stuff that
really does hit up against you know hard
sciences or hard engineering you know we
actually need to understand how humans
act over time and and what humans have
done at various points pressure points
or you know what they do when they get
into a big crowd versus what they do
when they disperse and there are
patterns you know they're not it's not
perfectly reproducible as a as an ideal
scientific experiment would be and
that's very frustrating because if only
we always just acted the same way all
the time we could fix a lot of problems
with humanity that's why it's better to
become a physicist than a sociologist
it's way easier to study atoms than
people yeah except except when there's
all these like there's like dark matter
and like you know magical particles
really is it simple because you just
like just put like dark in front of it
and then here's like is it dark matter
is it dark energy whatever you can
literally write down on one page a model
that fits all of the data right can you
even imagine doing that with people no I
mean it's just not of course we don't
know exactly what the dark matter is it
could be quite complicated but in terms
of explaining what you see out there in
galaxies in the universe the physics you
need to imagine the Dark Matter has is
actually really simple so I I'm very I'm
very happy and telling my students that
people with short attention spans should
go into physics rather than Social
Sciences because you can simplify things
way down and the thing still works
that's the miracle yeah I mean I do
think there are efforts to do that with
the social sciences I think game theory
is a great example of sort of social
science trying to reduce all of human
interactions to kind of these few basic
laws and that's what's wrong with game
theory is that you know it works
sometimes in some situations if you're
literally playing a game yeah
or actually I love in the the new movie
crazy rich Asians that game theory
becomes like an integral part of how to
have a romance which in fact is kind of
written into the history of game theory
in a way so anyway it works in some
cases but it certainly you know doesn't
explain all the ambach you to be fair i
think the game theory is just right in
terms of its mathematical demonstrations
of things but then the question as
always with math is are the assumptions
behind these theorems that you've proven
matching on to the situation that you
care about in reality and that's that's
where game theory or calculus or algebra
or anything can lead you wrong certainly
extrapolation and regression can lead
you terribly terribly wrong
that's right yeah and a lot of that does
I mean it does end up coming down to as
you're set like the fact that individual
humans sometimes react in ways that we
don't expect crowds of humans sometimes
react in ways that we don't expect and
it's you can say okay there's these
general we see these general rules if we
look at the long arc of recorded history
in the West we can say alright you know
we see you know general patterns
emerging in terms of how people group
together and what kinds of political
structures they seem to enjoy but
there's a huge variety of those
political structures there's a huge
variety of ways that we've gotten
together so it's hard I mean it's this
is so tempting to be like alright I'm
gonna come up with the universal theory
of human relationships of human
development in some ways and you know
everybody's tried it Karl Marx tried to
do it in the nineteenth century and you
know it's it doesn't it doesn't ever
completely work yeah I think we even
know why it doesn't work out right I
mean the famous example is Isaac Asimov
in psycho history right and he had in
mind you think was pretty explicit in
the novels he had this analogy when you
have a bunch of atoms in a box of gas
you can extrapolate general rules for
their behavior as a fluid right
thermodynamics and statistical mechanics
so of course when you get many people
you can do the same thing but as a
physicist there's an obvious flaw in
that reasoning which is that in the case
of atoms
they just simply bump into each other
and respond in a very linear way small
things remain small or even gets
smoothed out wild fluctuations get
canceled out by all the other
fluctuations whereas in a group of human
beings who interact very strongly and
non linearly tiny fluctuations can be
amplified very very strongly it is
absolutely possible from a physics point
of view to understand why groups of
people can be influenced by individuals
that have a strong impact on the others
yeah I'm reading a novel right now
called an unkindness of ghosts by Rivers
Solomon which just came out it's it's
really great it's a generation ship
novel and so it's set in the future
because you know we don't have
generation ships yet and that's what
they'll have you believe yeah I'm sure
that like you know HAARP is working on
it but one of the things that's great in
in Solomon's novel is that she deals
with the way that this generation ship
has recreated plantation life and so
they have slaves and servants who are
living in the lower decks and doing all
the scut work and then they have kind of
the plantation owners and it does break
down along familiar racial lines in this
book where there's sort of lighter
skinned people on top darker skinned
people on the bottom and this is a great
example of that of an author trying to
play with what you're talking about
where a tiny or a large fluctuation
continues to echo over centuries you
know so there's been this incredible
historical disturbance of the slavery of
Africans in the United States and it
doesn't just go away it doesn't like the
the kind of ripples that have propagated
out from that historical trauma just
don't you know you you would hope like
you would wish that they would just kind
of bump into other things and like that
those ripples would like bump into the
Obama presidency and be like aha
everything's fixed but it isn't fixed
and in fact sometimes the effects get
bigger over time or they return in new
ways that are just as pernicious and so
that's the fun part of being a writer
it's the sad part of history but the fun
part of being
is thinking about how there are these
social effects that can have very
unexpected consequences and also that
they can continue you know to me like
writing about the future that's one of
the pleasures of it is I think for some
science fiction writers the pleasure is
coming up with all the new [ __ ] you know
like oh my god we're gonna have you know
faster than light travel or we're gonna
you know implant other personalities
inside our heads and to me I was I was
really interested in how how would
history you know come back in some new
form and how would we continue to have
some of the same struggles which is
probably partly why I was excited about
talking about economics because I don't
think in a hundred and fifty years we're
gonna have gotten rid of capitalism and
we're not going to be you know science
is not magically gonna pay for itself
and so I really wanted to like think
about how people in the future would
still be even though there's many many
things that are different even though
they have hard AI which is a kind of
magical dubious thing but they also are
still trying to get grants and they're
still struggling especially inequality
tell us a little bit more about exactly
what you imagined economically in
autonomous or in fact to tell us about
autonomous just a little bit so those
have not yet read it
shame on you can follow along so
autonomous is about a pharmaceutical
pirate she is a former academic
synthetic biologist and wants to bring
medicine to people who are poor or just
don't have any money at all who don't
have access to it and she's found that
working in academia isn't allowing her
to do that there's too much there's too
much political stuff there's too many
corporations that want to hold on to
those drug patents so she becomes a
pirate and starts creating versions of
these expensive medicines for free or
for very cheap to give to people who
can't afford them and she comes on the
radar of the corporation whose drugs
she's ripping off and they send a couple
of
agents after her basically to render her
because they don't there's a couple of
other things that they're trying to
cover up that she knows about and render
here being a euphemism for exterminating
pretty much they're not the the
corporation isn't worried about really
yeah
and so the agents who come after her
become main characters in the book as
well and we switched back and forth
between Jack the pirate and pallid in
the robot who is part of this team of
agents chasing after Jack and so the
world that they're in is a world where
basically the UN has been replaced by a
group that I call the International
Property coalition so human rights have
kind of been superseded by property
rights and that's kind of how people
think of human rights is in the context
of property which makes sense because
robots are human equivalent in this
world and they are born indentured to
pay off the cost of their manufacture
and eventually through some legal
shenanigans that have happened in the
past and there's like a tiny info dump
where we learn this in the book humans
also are now subject to what they call
the human rights indenture laws so you
have the lucky right that if you need to
you can sell yourself to someone and
they will own you for a set period of
time and of course there's a ton of
abuses in the system and basically it's
a it's a story about the future of
slavery and how how do we reinvent
slavery and give it a bunch of
euphemisms and a big part of that is the
economic system in one of the sort of
large economic coalition's that we see a
lot which is kind of a combination of
north it's basically North America it's
Canada and the US have become this kind
of free-trade zone and in order to work
or own a house or go to school in the
free trade zone you have to buy a
franchise in a city and when you do that
you know you pay a certain amount of
money to get in and then you pay every
year and then you get free health care
you get the right to work and live there
you get free schooling you get free
internet
you know emergency services all the
things that you would expect to get paid
for by the government in our world well
not all of those but many of those we
dream about them yeah we dream about
some of those but things like having
roads and having access to education and
things like that we kind of think of as
just well that's just what you get you
know of course you have roads you know
that's part of what you pay taxes for at
a minimum we also imagine that you know
in our world we think oh well you should
have the right to work anywhere and in
this future you know that has that right
just hasn't doesn't exist anymore you
know if you want to work somewhere you
have to pay in there's this parallelism
for human beings who are allowed to sell
themselves into indenture and AI robots
which are sort of automatically there
until they can buy their way out if I am
remembering it correctly yeah so
basically when robots are pretty much
when all robots are born and these are
these are of course artificially
intelligent robots so they're they're
you know they their consciousness isn't
like a human's but it is equivalent to a
human's they have you know feelings and
desires and things like that
so yeah so there the law says that they
can be indentured for up to ten years
- whoever manufactures them like I said
to pay off the cost of their manufacture
and not all robots survive that period
of time but if they do then they are
given an autonomy key and are allowed to
kind of go be productive members of
society and we do get to see a couple
moments of where we meet some robots
that have gotten out of indenture and
they you know one of the things they
love to do is just go shopping they're
basically people they're like now we're
free and so we'll go shopping at a mall
in Vancouver so the so the the economy
is you know it's a hyper capitalist
economy where you know a lot of the
things that we think of as our rights
which have nothing to do with capitalism
they just have to do with how the United
States was set up those rights have been
taken away like I said the right to work
wherever you want the right to live
wherever you want but they have been
replaced
by new property rights where you can pay
to work where you want and pay to live
where you want and so that's why people
get indentured because if you don't have
enough money to pay to be part of a city
or or some other community you're just
gonna die unless you sell yourself again
those are your choices die or become
indentured so it reminds us that we do
take things for granted right both
explicitly and implicitly in our laws we
have rights that we label and some I was
talking to a law professor on a
different episode of the podcast not yet
released but about the fact that there's
a lot of things we think should be
rights that no one ever thought to put
in the Constitution because everyone
knows that their rights right and we
might even have mentioned that the right
to work as as one of them and but that
can be taken away especially if the
economic system changes it's it's very
true and it was because I was talking to
an economist as I was coming up as I was
doing world-building on this that I
thought about that because he pointed
out this is our friend Noah Smith I bet
right our friend Noah Smith who is a
dedicated dystopian thinker and he's a
pretty cheerful guy um
know that you know on Twitter yes
notorious Twitter personality and he he
said exactly what we're saying you know
he was like well we think that we should
just be allowed to live wherever we want
but actually that's a really amazing
right to just have that at birth like a
lot of civilizations didn't have that
and don't have that so so basically I
just had to take away some of these
basic rights from my characters and
suddenly it made perfect sense that
people would choose to be indentured and
and indeed I mean even in our world now
like there's plenty of jobs that people
do that are basically indenture I mean
well kind of like being a grad student
for example and I was definitely
thinking of that I spent many many years
as a grad student and I definitely had a
grumpy feeling about my employment
situation we prefer apprenticeship to
indentured servitude which is just
another way of saying indenture you know
it's like your and in fact you're paying
in you know it's the university system
is like you pay in in order to have the
right to work there at least in my
experience and you know I mean some
people get fancier deals probably but
the poor a humanities graduate student
physics graduate students get paid it's
true yeah I mean we got paid a little
bit and I was you know I was kind of on
the border with Social Science so maybe
but we yeah it certainly was not in some
ways it's good that it's not like
science cuz there's nobody who has to
scramble to get money to pay us because
there's no money there's no money but
the department kind of would try to hand
out jobs in a relatively equitable way
so you know it's like here's a thousand
dollars for this semester
everybody gets a thousand dollars for
the semester yeah and how did it work in
terms of the mechanics of writing the
novel going back and forth between world
building and storytelling I presume that
the world building influences the
storytelling but do you have you know
pages and pages of unpublished world
building materials stuck on your hard
drive somewhere I do have an
embarrassingly large amount of world
building materials that never made it in
a lot of stuff I think has to be barely
painted in the background because you
know readers don't want to wade through
like a giant info down for it's like as
you know Bob like in this world here's
how indenture works and you know as you
move into the cities this is what's
happening so really like the book the
way the book comes together I think are
came together for me and I think the way
novels generally come together for me as
it starts with characters and I start to
think about the world that they're in
and then I have to really focus on the
character to write the book and I feel
like that's kind of laying the
groundwork is okay here's the characters
here's what happens to them here's how
they change or don't change and then I
have to come back again kind of at the
end and say okay so what are the rules
of the world I need to smooth this out
and make sure everything is consistent
otherwise
every nerd in the universe is gonna be
smacking their face as they read this
book because it's just completely
incoherent in terms of how the world
works I mean that's interesting I think
and I noticed this with my wife Jennifer
who's also a science writer and that we
write an awesome science writer that was
implicit we write our books very
differently and I'm guessing that if I
were to write a novel I would write it
very differently than that like I would
have to do all the world-building first
and then have to come up with what the
characters are doing in that world just
like when I write my non-fiction books I
start with chapter one and then chapter
two and then chapter three and Jennifer
could start with chapter seven just like
it's no big deal and it drives me crazy
I definitely with with both my fiction
and nonfiction writing because I do
non-fiction books as well I have to
start with chapter one too and I I know
people like Jennifer who are like no but
start in the middle and and I have
writer friends who do fiction who they
you know they'll they'll kind of write a
bunch of scenes and then figure out
where they go and that drives me crazy I
have to know I have to know what the
world is and I have to know what they
care I have to start with the characters
from the beginning and go to the end and
it's true with when I get to the end I
go back to the beginning and sort of
clean everything up but yeah I'm very
linear I guess I live in linear time so
I try to honor that in my work and it's
one of the good things about different
ways of creating things I remember when
we did a science consult with Ridley
Scott for one of his movies that hasn't
been made yet he was going to adapt the
Forever War but the Joe Haldeman novel
and yeah so there was no script written
yet of course the novel had been written
but it was clear that Ridley Scott had
in his mind certain very specific scenes
all painted out right like he knew
visually what was going to be like and
the words you know they would they would
appear you know to fit whatever you
wanted to happen but he knew what it
would look like from the start and
that's yet another way to start with a
project like that yeah and I think I
mean for sure like the novel I'm working
on right now which I'm almost done with
like there were certain scenes that I
knew I wanted in there toward the end
I kept thinking I didn't write them down
because I didn't I wasn't there yet but
I was so like just the other day I wrote
one of them finally and I was like yes I
finally wrote that scene and you know so
there is definitely like you I feel like
in TV writing people call them beats and
it's you know you know where the beats
are gonna be and then you kind of write
yourself into them and you like sorry
let me back up there's a whole long
tradition of scientists diving in and
writing the occasional science fiction
novel with mixed results shall we say
right I mean we're we're trained through
a lifetime of being an academic to talk
and think one way and being a fiction
writer is very different now you got
your start as a science writers I guess
is a tech writer and then a science
writer and then you made the transition
into fiction so what was that like were
you always planning to write fiction at
some point or was it a huge change of
gears it was a pretty big change of
gears I already I thought I had already
been through the big transition when I
moved from writing as an academic to
writing popular work writing journalism
and sort of pop science and and also of
course I switched from kind of a
humanities focus to looking at tech and
science so I was like okay I'm done with
all my big transitions and yeah it never
really works out that way and so making
the transition from academic writing to
popular writing I have to say was
actually much more difficult in many
ways than transitioning from science
nonfiction to science fiction because
when you're writing for an academic
audience you're trying to do so many
things that are very different like
you're not worried about popular or mass
appeal you often are like buried in a
long tradition of thought and so you're
having to kind of talk about here's what
everybody else in this field has done
here's my one tiny contribution that
like takes us slightly forward into the
left and with pop fiction and nonfiction
you don't have to do
as much of that kind of work I mean part
of your job is also just to engage the
reader which you know is a whole it's a
whole craft that you have to learn how
to be engaging and how to tell a story
that people want to keep reading okay so
my dad academics have zero training or
interest in learning about yeah right
and that but that was actually like hard
it's like a hard transition because one
of the things that's one of the freedoms
that academic writing gives you is to be
as weird and quirky as you want and like
have like a title for your essay that's
like some weird play on an 18th century
poem and like the three people that read
that article are gonna be like yes
that's so funny and hilarious
and you feel like wow I was that so
sophisticated they're like 90 levels of
references there and like that's not
something you can do and popular fiction
I mean in in some limited ways you can
do that for sure and I I definitely have
like weird obscure references in my
books but that can't be the whole thing
you know you also have to tell story
that's like that's that people can
relate to you and that speaks to a lot
of people and not just like the five
people that are interested in like
Marxist cultural studies which is what I
was doing so you think that the
experience of going through that
transition and becoming a popular
science writer was extremely helpful for
your next transition into fiction it
really was because I had already before
I wrote autonomous or actually I should
say in the middle of writing autopsies I
wrote a really shitty first draft which
I put away and then wrote scatter adapt
and remember which is a nonfiction
science book about mass extinction and
how humans will survive the current mass
extinction and that book I did a lot of
learning about how to structure an arc
in an in a book you know like how to
make it have a beginning middle and end
I don't think I fully succeeded but I
definitely but the failures there helped
teach me oh you know I need to have this
kind of connective tissue
you know Aristotle was right about
storytelling right I mean this is a
reason why some
and pointed out that why Hollywood
movies do well compared to a lot of
foreign films it's not that Hollywood
movies appeal to the lowest common
denominator but they understand story
structure there are acts there are
conflicts that get resolved at the right
time and that's a whole skill to have to
learn yeah it's there's that's a big
part of it and certainly I mean I've
been reading science fiction my whole
life and so I definitely have like a
template in my head where it's like oh
you know this is how you tell a story
you do what Octavia Butler would do or
you do what Orsola Quinn would do and
you know there have been many times when
I've thought what would Octavia Butler
what would Octavia do yeah and like and
she would basically you know she's
famous for having spent lots of time
with false starts and revision and you
know writing like half a novel and
tossing it aside because she was very
exacting about how to tell a story and
that's why her stories are so engaging
and like stick with you for so long
so I think I I really enjoyed making the
transition I was really surprised that
it worked so well and I was even more
surprised that people actually liked
autonomous because I thought it was just
gonna be like a weird book about like
robot sex and people would be there'd be
like four it'd be like my academic
writing like four people would be like
this is the greatest thing ever and
everybody else would be like that book
happened I don't know so I was so
gratified that my um you know weird
ideas and my my efforts to make them
appeal to more than just me actually
kind of worked to be to be fair there is
robot sex there in the book or actually
is there robot sex there's robot on
human sex I mean that's robot sex robots
robotic but um yeah and I mean that was
part of what you know like there's some
quirky stuff in this novel and so you
know as well as you know of course my
exegesis on the future of economics
there's also you know human
relationships and romance and stuff like
that so and I think that's part of what
people really liked even though pallet
and the robot does some mean things
she's also a really relatable character
and
she's kind of just been born in a way
she's just been booted up so she's
learning not to be a jerk well we have
to talk about palate in a little bit
palate in the robot what we talked about
the economics and how that goes into the
world-building there's also a lot of
ideas in the novel about AI and robots
in general and so one of the things you
already touched on so I just wanted to
touch on it again we're certainly
sympathetic with paladin right I mean
it's you know she's discovering herself
and sort of a newbie in the world and an
ingenue and discovering things and then
she kills people pretty ruthlessly all
the time and yeah it's almost like you
have to read it twice like did that
really just happen was that a
intentional kind of mood setting device
or how did that come to you so paladin
was the first character that came to me
in the novel so that I sort of started
with paladin and and kind of ended with
paladin too because when I when I did my
major revision paladin was the character
that changed the most
and I I felt like I I liked characters
who are complex and in a gray area and
this is a robot that was designed to be
a combat robot like you know there's no
question why paladin is there is
basically just to you know do some
reconnaissance and then do some killing
killing people part of the job yeah part
of the programming part of the job and
part of his programming and he starts
out as basically owned by a military
branch of the African Federation and the
African Federation is kind of like the
EU for African nations in this future
and so it's a bunch of African nations
kind of sharing the same currency and
things like that so so he's owned by the
African Federation everyone just kind of
assumes he's a he because if you're a
big giant bulky Terminator looking
[ __ ] you must be a dude and he
doesn't really care one way or the other
but but his robot gender identity he's a
robot he's like whatever I don't really
have gender but as the book goes along
and he starts learning more about people
and
how people relate to each other and what
they think of as being important he
starts to he wants to change his pronoun
so she becomes she in the middle of the
book kind of arbitrarily for a bunch of
reasons that I don't want to spoil and
so she kind of goes through some of the
things that a human teenager might go
through you know she's she's just been
booted up she's kind of questioning the
role that she's been assigned in the
world she's questioning who she is and
who she can love and and you know how
she wants humans to perceive her because
changing her pronoun of course is all
about you know what humans perceive
because again robots don't really care
about gender that much so I I wanted
people to like have this sort of crunchy
difficult relationship with Paladin and
not have it be just like Paladin is a an
innocent sweet robot you know Paladin
crushes people's brains like that's her
job and you know she eventually toward
the end is kind of like huh why am i
doing this job well just kill some more
people brain crushing is that really my
purpose yeah and she never has again I
mean I I don't kind of spoon-feed the
reader like she never has a moment where
she kind of scratches her head and is
like what his meaning of life but she
does start questioning her programming
and she's given a chance to really see
how she's been programmed and that's a
really important turning point and again
for me this was a lot of it was thinking
about what it again what it's like to be
a teenager or what it's like to become a
young adult and suddenly you realize
that there's all this stuff you're doing
just because you've been told that you
should do it and just because you've
been told it's right and you know lots
people for example grow up with
religious programming and they just have
never questioned it and all of a sudden
they're like wait why am i doing all
this stuff do I really believe this how
do i how do I want to be religious do I
want to be and paladin's kind of going
through something like that with her
programming is kind of rethinking all
the stuff she's been taught and so that
was so fun to write especially because
you know unlike a person who can't Ness
Sara Lee go into their own mind and be
like I have here I have discovered the
programming called Catholic Church and
now I can remove it because you just
can't do that
you can't remove it if you're a person
but for a robot she actually can go in
eventually and see all the programs
she's running and be like oh that's why
I was feeling that way oh I could modify
that um so like robots would be great in
therapy that's what I think it will all
be very not a very lucrative customer
because no fix that maybe go away that's
not what a therapist once at all yeah I
mean but it might be really complex like
if my therapist might have to
essentially like a robot therapists
would have to be basically some kind of
programmer or maybe even a hacker you
know cuz you'd have to build little
hacks to kind of get around like well
you need this program but this program
is also telling you to like fall in love
with guys who are really bad for you but
we want to keep part of the program but
not that other part so you know it could
be complex well I so I have thoughts on
this both ways one is it's it's
provocative to think about an
artificially intelligent mind being able
to pinpoint programs that give them
motivation to do certain things in
certain ways because it teaches us or
makes us think something about human
beings like in some sense we're robots
we're computers anyway we're physical
organisms there's things in our brains
going on and they might imagine
pinpointing oh there's the part of my
brain that makes me fall in love with
bad boys who I know will cheat on me and
would we want to go in there you know
pay money to the surgeon to go in there
and fix that part of our brain yeah I
mean that's kind of the question that's
asked in the movie the Eternal Sunshine
of the spotless mind where yeah there's
a technology I love that movie and I'm
sure it it's sort of part of what
influenced me and that that in that
movie there's a technology where you can
nuke a set of memories so that you you
know you can forget a mean person in
your life or maybe you can forget your
your lust for bad boys or whatever so
yeah I think that that is a question
that you know these characters have to
deal with for Paladin that's less of a
concern because
she can see all of the modifications
she's making and but there are that said
there are moments where she's having to
second-guess the humans around her
because she knows that the humans don't
have that same ability and so she has to
say okay is this person speaking to me
out of their programming or do they
really mean it
and again that's a very human question
because you never know is this person
just being polite or did they really
like me
and so that's that's it you know and so
the fun thing with paladin is that while
she's having these very human thoughts I
also you know based her consciousness on
basically a UNIX system and thought
about how you know early UNIX computers
networked with each other and what would
it be like if you had a consciousness
that had kind of grown out of computer
networks and how would you how would
these AIS communicate with each other
and so I have them doing you know secure
handshakes and when they meet each other
they're speaking to each other
wirelessly that robots are and kind of
announcing themselves in the same way
that you know data announces itself to a
computer on the network where it says
hello here comes my data so I'm kind of
translating from you know what packets
are saying because they support and so I
felt like I made Paladins sufficiently
alien and sufficiently connected to a
tradition of computer Minds that you
know some of her problems really aren't
human problems like some of her problems
are really like network security
problems and you know there is a whole
bit where she has to kind of she kind of
has to deal with what it means to have a
mind that is stored in the cloud and she
doesn't control that you know her the
company that owns her basically owns her
backups which is her mind and so that's
a thing that humans haven't really had
to deal with quite yet and not in a
literal sense anyway and I think that
this does also raises questions about
artificial intelligence so I think that
the the fact that Paladin can sort of
pinpoint
in her brain certain programs that make
her feel certain ways provokes us into
thinking a certain way about human free
will right but on the flip side of that
I am a little skeptical that artificial
intelligence would work it has sort of
conscious human level AI if you couldn't
reprogram yourself you know I mean I
hear so many conversations about
artificial intelligence that are about
how we should program the computer so it
doesn't do bad things and I can't really
imagine that that would qualify as
artificial intelligence if it couldn't
change its mind in some profound way I
completely agree with you and one of the
things I've said about this book over
and over is that it's it is science
fiction but there is this fantasy at the
heart of it which is that we just sort
of wave our hands and have strong AI and
don't ask any questions because I think
that in real life
as we explore more and more what machine
learning means and what it means to
build machine learning algorithms into
other applications we're realizing that
first of all we don't know what the hell
intelligence is at all like in humans in
anything like we are totally square one
with that and I mean sure there's a lot
of people have a lot of different
definitions but you know trying to
recreate something that we can't even
quantify in ourselves is really tough um
the other thing that I think we're
learning is that intelligence to the
extent that it can be talked about is
really an ecosystem there's different
kinds of intelligence and I'm not just
talking about dumb stuff like emotional
intelligence which I think whatever
that's like a self-help book thing I
mean kinds of intelligence that work on
different kinds of problems intelligence
that presents itself as maybe not
seeming very intelligent or but actually
is brilliant at doing some one
particular task or a set of tasks and I
think the whole movement around sort of
the idea of neurotypical 'ti being
actually not really that typical is
really helping us in a way much more
than then you might
think in terms of defining intelligence
because once we have an idea that
there's a spectrum of what it means to
have consciousness and intelligence and
it's not just like here's the one kind
of consciousness that we recognize as
intelligent and everything other than
that is like autistic or you know
schizophrenic or whatever the other
names are that we're using at whatever
point in history so which is a very
abstract way of saying that when we
actually if we ever do have something
that resembles what gets called strong
AI which is basically human equivalent a
AI it may actually look nothing like
Paladin it may express itself in ways
that are really hard for us to relate to
it may be like talking to a very non
neurotypical person and we're gonna have
to learn to kind of translate from those
machines and I think some of them might
turn out to be kind of like Paladin but
I agree with you that if we really
wanted to imitate a human mind it would
have to be self modifying in some way
and if it weren't self-modifying I don't
know if I would say it couldn't be human
equivalent but it would be equivalent to
a human who had been horribly abused and
and kind of culturally programmed like
maybe like a cult victim or something
like that
someone who hadn't been allowed to make
any choices and and as a result maybe
was you know had experienced a huge
amount of trauma yeah so if you can
imagine go ahead go ahead I think my own
suspicion is that my own suspicion is
that we'll have a hundred different
kinds of artificial intelligence before
we have anything that is really like a
human being I think that we way
underestimate how hard it is to get
something that's like a human being I
think it will happen there's no obstacle
in principle but there's many different
ways to be intelligent weird its
discovering this already it's way easier
to build a computer that will win at
chess than a computer that will carry on
a fun conversation with you and part of
that is that it's not just you know
processing power but it's also
motivations it's our brains are embodied
in our body
that you know get hungry and thirsty and
want to reproduce and you want to sing
songs and it's gonna be it you could
have other motivations for an embodied
robot but they wouldn't be the same so I
would be surprised if the first second
third fourth generations of AI were
anything like human beings at all I
think I mean as as we've been saying I
think it's gonna be an ecosystem so I
think there's going to be some ai's
whose motivations are incredibly
difficult for us to relate to we might
know what those motivations are but they
won't fit anything we won't be able to
feel those motivations in the same way
an AI might on the other hand if we do
assume that we can create a human
equivalent a AI and program it we might
very well program it to have the same
kinds of [ __ ] up desires that humans
do right like it might we might give it
what what Foucault calls a perverse
implantation which is this is way of
talking about how we sort of teach
people to to think that their own
desires are terrible and wrong even
though we feel them all the time because
they're as you said where we live in
meat sacks and we have built-in urges
and needs but using culture we can try
to train people that these urges and
needs are bad and and can modify them
right so we can modify how people want
to have sex or we can modify how people
want to eat that's why people have so
many weird rituals around sex and food
because these are these basic things
that we want and culture has just like
swarmed all over them and like mess them
up and made them complex in ways that
are like infinite you know like that
just like infinite complexity laid on
top of like basically just eating and
reproducing people these are not complex
activities but we've we've really we
fetishized them to the point of like
absurdity and so I think you could
imagine a robot that you know had a lot
of hangups
Martha Wells has a great series called
murder bot which is a series of novellas
which I highly recommend where she has a
robot who has a lot of social problems
and partly due to its programming
due to the fact that like paladin it's
kind of a murder bot you know it's a
murder bot it's designed to kill and
protect and and it copes with all of its
problems and all of its hang-ups by
downloading a huge amount of soap operas
to its local memory and then just
watching soaps and and it's you know
it's this very human
you know tick that this robot has but it
made me think about how we really could
through cultural conditioning create AI
that are very human and that learn about
life from from stories and that you know
crave stories in the same way that
people do and so I think you know like I
said it's gonna be an ecosystem and it's
gonna be way weirder than we thought I
don't think we're gonna have a robot
uprising I think it's much more like
robots and AI and machine learning will
kind of merge into human society in ways
that are sometimes hard to tell apart
from human society like if you get an
implant that's kind of an AI or you kind
of become partly a I I think it's that
the I think we're gonna end up with a
spectrum it you know where it's there's
totally biological human intelligence
all the way on the other side is like
totally machine intelligence and you
know everything in the middle yeah I
think that's exactly right and I'm on
your side there did you get do you do a
lot of conversing with AI experts and
robot experts for the novel just like
economics I did yes I talked to I talked
to hardware experts about how a robot
body would be put together because that
was something that I didn't know very
much about I read a lot about AI and
machine learning I had also already been
you know writing in my journalism a lot
about it and a lot about just computer
networks in general I used to when I
first started my career I wrote a lot
about computer security and hacking
which is actually a great way to learn
about computer networking because it's
all about the ways that you know
subversive activities can take place and
people can kind of sneak around all of
the protocols or all
you know all of the things that are
supposedly safe and so it's in a way
it's almost like studying computer
security or writing but is almost like
looking at computer network neurosis
because it's all about how to write like
unwanted thoughts and and applications
appear in this like good pure mind of
the computer or mind of your network of
computers and so so I had kind of all of
that stuff in my head and it had been
sitting in my head for a pretty long
time so I was like at last you can
finally use this knowledge to build a
robot so your grand unified theory is
that everything we do is a kind of
therapy for one thing or another or the
opposite right like that everything we
have everything is a neurosis and while
we're doing is trying to you know deal
with our neurosis become functionally
neurotic hands or machine I mean and
just to like not kill each other like
ultimately like I think a lot of my work
including the novel I'm working on now
like the big struggle is just like just
don't kill each other you know wait I
know you're mad I know you're feeling
neurotic but just you know put the gun
down no brain crushing let's just work
it out like grown-up robots speaking of
neurotic you also there's a whole sort
of yet another technological angle in
autonomous where there are these
synthetic drugs being made and then
pirated that's what Jack does for a
living and so you also talked into
pharma people and biochemists about how
drugs could make you more or less
neurotic or helpful or less yes I did
talk to a lot of very kind and
sympathetic biologists I talked to a
couple of synthetic biologists I talked
to a genetic engineer about kind of
about the lab scenes I gave him an early
copy of the book and it was really funny
because he was like well you know
actually the lab scenes are fine like
and you know this is all you know this
is all good but you call there's this
one machine that you have and it it's a
fab and you're like why is everything a
fab ER like that is not how it would
work
like there would be it might have the
same technology but like there'd be a
bunch of different special use cases and
all different kinds of Fabrice so that
is just terrible and so I actually did
go in and and change it so that a lot of
things now that we used to be called a
Fabri have other names there's like
cookers and there's you know devices
again special use devices that are
basically 3d printers that grow and
print tissue or print you know print
various molecular structures and stuff
like that so so that was really helpful
and then I did talked to neuroscientists
about the drug that the characters are
taking which is getting them addicted to
work and they and it was like okay
here's how the drug would work and what
do you think and they were like oh yeah
Wow
that could work oh that's so evil yes oh
very evil so they were excited about the
evil it's all the time I mean what I'd
have done the movie consulting you know
it's physicists consulting with people
making movies is fairly straightforward
right like the answer to everything is
you need a wormhole to do it but you
don't need a physics consultant you just
need an AI chat but to say yes you need
a wormhole just put the wormhole in
there it's not realistic but you need it
anyway but if you want if the if you're
a writer producer whatever and you say
okay I need an organism you know a germ
that will go in and have the following
terrible effect on humankind the
biologist will go no I don't think that
oh oh yeah oh yeah sure we can do that
no problem and it's kind of scary from
that point of view yeah and in fact like
I just outright stole some ideas with
permission from from some of the
biologists I talked to I have like a
final you know final boss fight scene
where they're using a bunch of cool
futuristic technology there's sort of
repurposing stuff and and the biologists
I was talking to said oh but you know
you couldn't do that but you could do
this other thing which would cause his
skin to like erupt with stuff and I was
like oh yes so anyway that's not too
much of a spoiler but me to do this this
is the best thing ever how could I get a
job so good
yeah well I also just like I always have
like a warm feeling when a scientist
tells me that something is plausible
even if they're sort of saying like with
a caveat that of course it's not
plausible
it's like when you told me about
wormholes I was like okay I can use
wormholes because Sean said it's okay
even though he said also wormholes
couldn't really exist but he said they
kind of maybe possibly exist there are
different levels there's an ecosystem of
violating the laws of physics right yes
so that's perfectly there's acceptable
ones and less acceptable ones yeah yeah
exactly I think the thing that's most
important to me when representing
science is trying to represent the
scientific process accurately which is
to say sure showing people testing
things and retesting them and like how
do you test things you know like I have
a character who's testing photonic
molecule levels which is not a thing
there is not photonic molecules but but
you would in fact have to go test the
levels on on a device over and over to
kind of make the sub positions that she
does so I wanted at least to be honest
in that way so that people understand
that science is actually a lot of dreary
testing and not a lot of gazing
rapturously into glowing holes and
saying like we'll allow some absurdity
but we want our absurdities to be
grounded in the scientific method as
much as possible exactly and how much of
the discussion of the intersection
between economics and pharma in the book
was a commentary of reflection or
inspired by the real world right now a
hundred percent inspired by the real
world I mean I I live in the real world
maybe to my detriment and so everything
I write about is you know my brain takes
it in and I either consciously or
probably a lot of times unconsciously
kind of smoosh it up and try to rethink
it and put it on the page so I've like a
lot of people in the United States I've
seen I've had many friends that suffered
horribly because they couldn't afford
medical treatments and so that was very
much on my mind and pharma companies are
huge like it's a huge business and it's
poorly understood and the way
that they make money overlaps a lot with
the patent system which is also poorly
understood and so you know it's a great
way to just rip people off and and you
always have a captive audience nobody's
gonna say no to a drug that's gonna cure
them or prolong their life so you know
it's it's easy in some ways it's an easy
target for a big bad but it's also a you
know it's it's a source of great anxiety
and pain for lots of people so it's you
know it seem like an obvious place to to
poke and who doesn't want a
pharmaceutical pirate like that's the
well I was gonna say your protagonist is
a biochemical pharmaceutical pirate so
that's pretty good yeah I think and it's
funny because after the novel came out a
few people have come out identifying as
pharmaceutical pirates and so I was
excited about that I was like yes steal
from the rich give to the poor that's
that's my my hope is that it is closer
to Robin Gabriel piracy right I mean
it's your real pirate sir yes in it for
themselves
it's at Jack's character is very much
like in the Robin Hood tradition is
explicitly thinking about Robin Hood who
is like one of my very favorite mythical
characters ever so and so why don't you
just give us a teaser for the next one
are you are you I should say are you
mostly a fiction writer now you're still
writing nonfiction also I am trying to
be bi which is hard
nobody really acknowledges these bye-bye
textual people like me but I am working
on two books right now one of which is
nonfiction which is about ancient
abandoned cities focusing on four cities
specifically and looking at why people
abandoned them even though they were
kind of cities that were at the heart of
their civilizations and sort of using
that to think about the modern world and
what we're going to do with our mega
cities and I'm also working on a novel
which is about time-traveling geologists
so it's great to be working on something
about ancient history while I'm also
writing about time travel because
whenever I feel the need like
desperately as I'm writing about
archaeology like I wish I could just go
back and fight
know what really happened I'm like I
will go over to my novel all they have
to do is like get a grant to use the
time machine in order to go back and
find out what happened so so it's it's
been a really fun past year although
very stressful and because I'm trying to
write a lot of stuff but but the novel
should be out next fall and the
non-fiction book will probably be out in
2020 yeah I mean I think there's a kind
of a theme here I don't want to sort of
force a theme where it's not there but
you've written about how we're going to
survive and apocalypse sorry what was it
titled that book again scatter adapt and
remember right how we will survive a
mass extinction yes and it depends the
mass extinction right and very much so
there's a lot of instructions in the
book yeah and now you have the book on
ancient cities where they I mean was it
mostly a No spoiler alert I suppose but
is it mostly that they chose to leave
them or were they forced to leave them
for some reason or another it's always a
combination in you know that these were
cities that were abandoned which means
that people you know left them they
weren't forced out by invading forces in
any of the cases I'm looking at in one
case like with Pompeii I mean the city
was buried in ash but other cities that
were buried in ash at that same time
were dug out and like Naples which was
you know affected as well but Pompeii
was not and so I'm looking at what are
the precipitating factors that turn a
huge city like say Angkor which had a
million people about a thousand years
ago which made it the biggest city on
earth at that time how did that go from
the biggest city on earth
and then within like four hundred years
to just a few monks living in you know
kind of ruined remains don't leave
neuroses for this you know I mean
there's the neuroses that you you know
once you get a bunch of humans together
in a city you know the neuroses become
things like historical trauma and you
know also like infrastructure upkeep
like that turns out to be a big issue
politics are a huge part of what causes
a city to fail but politics alone won't
do it it's really got to be combined
with some kind of environmental problem
whether the problem is actually climate
change or you know mismanaging the water
supply or whatever so so I don't know if
that's a neurosis or just but it is
certainly a recurring human problem yeah
we see it over and over again so scatter
adapt and remember that was the title
that's the title of my first book and
the nonfiction book I'm working on now
about abandoned cities is just called
for lost cities but I like scattered at
the remember is kind of a theme right
running through the fiction as well as
the nonfiction there's you know human
beings trying to adapt to challenging
circumstances and choosing different
modes of doing that
that's very true I mean for me in all of
my work I have a strong wish to urge
people to survive and try to survive in
a way that helps lots of other people
survive with them I mean I was joking
earlier about the whole goal with my
fiction is just to tell people not to
kill each other not going don't kill
that's number one
and I mean that's part of you know
that's a joke but also that is part of
what I'm trying to do in my nonfiction
is kind of show people ways that humans
have survived and how even when horrible
circumstances you know kick them out of
a really awesome city they still manage
to survive their culture lives on humans
live on and we create you know new
social structures that are hopefully a
little bit less inclined to encourage
people to kill each other you know
that's the goal just like less and less
pressure to kill more and more pressure
to you know take care of everyone so so
yeah survival and survival in style I
would say and survival in style is good
I noticed in one interview someone
wanted to paint autonomous as a
dystopian novel but you said it's just
the topia it's either a dystopian or a
utopia that's see the usual in-between
somewhere yeah just just how things are
now I mean sometimes things are a little
worse sometimes
a little better for certain groups of
people but yeah I mean I definitely
autonomous there's a lot of things that
happen that are yeah they were positive
you know there's great medicine
available if you can afford it so you
just need a pirate to help make that you
know a better system and and certainly
in in the time-travel novel I'm working
on now there's like there's some bad
stuff but there's some good stuff you
can't write a helpful where everyone's
happy and just sitting around saying how
happy there are but maybe the
descriptions of less than perfect
situations can help nudge us here in the
real world towards making things a
little bit better I think that's true
and I I don't think we're ever gonna
reach a point as a civilization or a
species where we're happy all the time
like even if we you know have an awesome
Gini coefficient and we don't have like
an extreme division between rich and
poor and we don't have like massive
social injustice we're still gonna argue
you know we're still gonna have jealousy
we're still gonna be sad when someone
dies or someone leaves us you know
there's always gonna be drama and
sadness it's just that hopefully we can
keep it on a kind of you know keep it on
the keep it limited back to my point
about not killing personal drama and not
have Wars I think that's a perfect note
to end on
annalee newest thanks so much for being
on the podcast yeah thank you for having
me
[Music]
you
[Music]